here's the thing people probably would
have but the issue is the issue isn't
even necessarily putting a date on
things before you know that you're ready
to put it out the issue is showing your
games too early in the [__] in the first
place you know like it is like why why
did you talk about the next Elder
Scrolls three years ago like don't do
that
how long ago did we see the first teaser
trailer three years ago it was it three
years 2019 29 to 20 it is 2023
yeah I'd rather complete silence and
shock me six months before the game's
about to come out
we saw a vowed uh I mean we we have some
form of hope that you know maybe
hellblade's end of the year beginning of
next year but you know that's not even
really oh